这是我用AI做的星光560骑士广告
为什么你的AI视频做不到这个正视度
其实不单单是提示词的问题
这个背后包含了一个非常重要的设计技巧
那就是美术设计
今天我将美术场景的搭建逻辑毫无保留地交给大家
想看成篇的直接滑到最后
接下来直接上实在
作为一个视频
首先我们要确定产品是给谁用的
这个其实它的定价针对的就是劳动人民
所以我在提案的时候就直接瞄准了三四五线的家庭
本次AI生成视频的流程是
1. 美术设计
2. 图片分镜头生成
3. 图生视频
后期编辑本次不讲
为了出第一张美术的基调图
我用了是海量战术
靠提示词反复的去试探
反复调试最后才跑出这个效果
整体质感是非常好的
这里给大家看大概的一些提示词
我把真实环境这个人物所存在的这个场景
在脑子里想好
我们在这里可以用Bunada和Image 2
这种比较厉害的模型去做
同时要主动规避很多问题细节
比如这个画面里的车牌原本是真实地区信息
我都会做细节处理去符合规范
还有场景里的这个招牌
它其实换成面馆更合适
让画面这个逻辑更通畅
AI创作人的判断永远是高于AI的
这个阶段不要让AI完全替代你的工作
而是让它承担一部分工作
我们来做最核心的判断
你的审美是用来把控整体的
就这一张图就花了非常多的心思和时间
再比如这个画面的物料
它都会去找到一个平衡点
介于真实质感和干净画面之间
同时把这个多余的三方品牌信息全部改掉
当然下次有品牌帮找我我就把这个保留了
开个玩笑
这就是美术设计的重要性
一个场景就包含了我们所有的信息
夫妻应用搬货的矛盾点
街上路人
一个小区的商铺
还有刚刚走的货车
潜意识它不会骗人
这些设计在一张图里面体现了多个信息
创作的前提是你要会感受生活
包括我在生人物镜头的时候
你可以尝试把焦段信息给AI
焦段是什么需要大家去学最常见的镜头焦段
24357085
越大的焦段对画面的空间压缩就越大
这一部分是因为我之前有实拍的基础
这部分的话没有捷径
需要大家去扎实基本功
比如这里我给图片上的就是50毫米焦段的中远景
下面这个则是75焦段拉的近景
你用提值深图
无非就是把该拍摄的镜头变成了文字
当然如果你不懂摄影
这一部分的话
你一定会弱于刚转航过来的摄影师
然后我会告诉AI人物的情绪
有人在窃喜
为什么要这样写
因为他偷偷给老公买了车
而且这个车是之前老公想要的更大的家伦车
所有的这些都是服务于疫情
其实我最不愿意看到就是大家问我要提值词
我可以随便给大家展示一些
汽车往左开停下来没了
所以这种提值词大家拿到有什么用
我到底是选择给你鱼还是给你鱼网
上面这些内容就是鱼网
需要大家好好去销化
这类广告最核心的是讲故事
传递情绪
AI对于实拍它最大的优势就是多场景制作
降低成本精准的传递情绪
实拍其实更适合于产品功能的那些细节展示
我也不认为AI能完全替代实拍广告
未来两者都会发挥自己最大的优势
经过这次AI的行业洗牌
大家也能看清楚
行业其实是在重新定位生态
而不是谁替代谁
工具因为平权了
大家都能做得很好看
做点短片非常容易
但难的是整体完成度
你让它做个20秒都可以
但是整个广告可能就不行
希望这次AI的制作分享
能够帮助到各位制作人
包括品牌方
我是罐头
如果点赞高的话
我持续分散AI的创作思路和实操技巧
感谢大家的关注
我们下期再见
你就不能过来搭把手
搭什么手
你这明显又拉多了
我那箱啤酒和大米放哪
每次进货都这样
多跑一趟的油钱都够进两箱纸了
我当初叫你买个大点的车
你非说没用
那他又来怪我了
带文件
我哪敢怪你啊
才说你一句你就
爸
妈
你快进去写作业
一趟拉不完
我拉两趟就是了
谁告诉你拉不下的
咱家那车拉不下
他还拉不下吗
谁
这车可真能装啊
你啥时候买的
咋不早点给我讲
我这不想给你个惊喜吗
咱们去露营是不是也有着落了
是啊
我有什么时候说
不怕了
你看他
太轻太热了似的